this is the moment Antonio rudiger
claimed he was being subjected to racist
trance halfway through the match
it came after he was informed by Chelsea
Captain Caesar aspilaquetta that Blues
Defender Antonio rudiger was being
subjected to racist abuse
in an unprecedented move game officials
on the uefa's new three-step protocol
issued three Stadium warnings to
supporters
the announcement came after referee
Anthony Taylor implemented a procedure
initially formed by FIFA to deal with
discrimination
the alleged abuse came out of rudiger
was kicked in the chest by Tottenham
forward son hyung-min who was sent off
as a result
this latest incident has once again
shown the ugly side of football it
follows the recent Manchester derby
match which saw fans apparently making
racist gestures towards United players
in October England's black players faced
Nazi salute an abusive chants from fans
in Bulgaria Tottenham manager Jose
Mourinho says it was right for officials
to follow protocol we are one of
one of the clubs
we are one of the clubs but every Club
is together on these on this uh on this
situation and of course we are
disappointed but the protocols were
followed the club has also reiterated
that view in a statement saying we are
now conducting a thorough investigation
which will include liaising with Chelsea
and their players for their observations
any form of racism is completely
unacceptable and will not be tolerated
in our Stadium we take any such
allegations extremely seriously and
shall take the strongest possible action
against any individual found to be
behaving in such a way including Stadium
bands there is growing pressure on
football's governing bodies with some
players demanding urgent action
I just don't think it's enough I just
don't think it's enough and is it going
to stop I've always said that's why
I praise Raheem for when he come out and
stood up and being brave enough to do it
because I couldn't do it because I was
like no one cares no one's going to
listen
the professional footballers Association
says it is now time for Action they're
calling for a government inquiry into
racism and hate speech within football
no Phillips Sky News